[Music]
you know I do wish that this review of
landed within December but at least it
showed up after Halloween you know small
favors a Christmas Carol
so the Christmas special of Doctor Who
following series 5 my relationship with
the Christmas specials is often a
contentious one they have a tendency to
be a bit more frivolous play a bit more
fast and loose with just the show
overall with the tone
they just favor kind of a lighter vibe
and not that doctor who can't be light
and fun but the the Christmas specials
often have a very distinct flavor to
them which speaking personally is not
really what I care for all that much so
this one here's what I'll give this one
I would argue that this is the most
Christmassy Christmas special that ever
Christmas at least as far as Doctor Who
is concerned because pretty much all the
other Christmas specials the Christmas
elements are incidental it is a
coincidence of the timing and it
contributes to certain visual cues so
like the Christmas invasion we had the
killer Christmas tree and the Santa
robots the god the runaway bride had
almost no Christmas iconography because
it was all based around the wedding but
that was still you know a little de
Christmas the the Santa robots came back
there was the Christmas star and the sky
and then you had voyage of the Damned
which was set at Christmas and had a
little bit of the iconography but again
with all of those cases well and also an
end of time part one was technically a
Christmas special and in all those case
and also with the next doctor it being
Christmas doesn't actually impact the
plot it just happens to be Christmas
which is fine as far as these things go
but the thing of it is and I I just for
the record I just realized I forgot to
swap out for the circular glasses but
I'm not gonna switch cuz I want to roll
already but anyways the the thing of it
is this one definitely more than any one
prior Christmas actually impacts the
plot you wouldn't tell this story this
way if it wasn't Christmas all the
Christmas specials prior to this you
could remove the Christmas elements and
you basically don't have to change
anything substantive about the story the
narrative the plot progressions or the
characters involved you just change one
or two lines and a couple of the visual
elements everything else stays the same
not the case here down to its structure
this is informed by Christmas and you
can take that as a good thing as a or a
bad thing I would label it a bold thing
I and I do certainly appreciate on paper
the whole idea of really upping how
important Christmas is to the story
because it's factoring into this across
the board from the fact that it takes
both its title and its story structure
and its concept from the Christmas
Dickens Christmas classic A Christmas
Carol and that immediately makes
Christmas way more important and then
you have the elements of the recurring
Christmas they come back every year and
do this thing and the Christmas carols
actually end up being a function of it
all this matters a heck of a lot more to
the plot if you were to remove the
Christmas elements from this thing you
would actually have to restructure the
thing almost from the ground up because
it has so many cues and narrative nods
to a Christmas carol and and things of
that ilk so I do admire that the end
result is decent
because look doing riffs on a Christmas
carol is not a new idea there are a lot
of first of all straightforward
adaptations of a Christmas carol there's
also a lot of riffs on it you've got
Scrooged you've got stuff like the the
girlfriends of Christmas past you know
you've got all these things that take
these concepts on so many shows not even
sci-fi shows like from sitcoms to
animated things like so many things have
done their version of a Christmas carol
in one way or another you know got like
my instruction this story was Mickey's
Christmas Carol for crying out loud so
there isn't really much new that you can
bring to the story of you know Christmas
Pratt's Christmas present Christmas
future
that said switching up the reason for it
to be a much more practical not we're
not trying to necessarily save this
guy's soul that's coincidental if we
pull that off we're doing this for a
very real and practical purpose of
saving people on a cruise ship and it's
interesting seeing Doctor Who dip into
the idea of going back to change
someone's past in order to change who
they are
I'm glad the show doesn't get into it
too much because it's very morally iffy
because you're literally rewriting
someone's personality effectively or at
least you're trying to so I'm glad it's
something the show hasn't really done
since but it's kind of a neat idea and
also it should be said Michael Gambon
he's a great Scrooge I know the
characters not actually named Scrooge
but it's the Scrooge figure that he's
playing and he's really good at that
he's good at being nasty but he's also
good at having that turn because it's
not just a matter of being nasty and
them being nice it's the transition from
one to the other that he has to pull off
sometimes within the same single shot
and he can do that he's
quite good at it so that was really cool
too but then you get into things like
the flying fish which is the kind of
it's Christmas is allowed to be silly
level of whimsy that tends to not sit
super well with me
in these episodes and I'm not like above
flying fish but it's just so arbitrary
and I don't think they would imagine
they could get away with it at any time
other than a Christmas special just
because like I said the rules are a bit
more relaxed so that's a little bit
that's a little bit off stress doing
pretty good here here's some girl I
forgot how good some of his lines are in
this you know he's got the the psychic
paper I believe you'll see I'm
universally recognized as a mature adult
Oh finally shorted out too big a lie you
know things like that I really enjoyed
heat him just bopping around the way he
does he's got great energy for this but
also that mischievious look when he's
like oh I guess I'm the ghost of
Christmas past in which I'm kind of glad
he has that more mischievous thing going
on there and it's not just leavel
because like I said rewriting somebody's
personality you can't like be flippant
about that and he is putting more
thought and measure into actually doing
that which is good he should be Amy and
Rory are largely absent from the story
so there isn't a ton to say about them I
mean they're fine the two actors are
good together they have good chemistry
they are fine
the the woman who who does the singing
who plays Abigail she's fine my I should
have checked that I believe that is
actually her singing and she was hired
primarily for her singing and her acting
is fine it's fine it's not amazing but
it's fine
the her singing is quite good so I would
say this overall is on the upper end of
the christmas specials for me because
while I don't love like if I measure
this against the scale of any other
doctor
episode I don't really love it but if I
measure it on the scale of the Christmas
specials you know which is a different
metric I like it pretty well and I
certainly appreciate the fact that being
a Christmas special is much more
integral to what's going on then is
usually the case with these things for
that alone I appreciate it especially
because like honestly I whether you air
it at Christmas or not how just tokens
some of the Christmas nods were in the
previous specials like it's nice to see
something where there was more thought
put into it being Christmas special I'm
like what can we actually really do with
that the end results I think it's I
think it is a good execution of what
it's trying to be what it's trying to be
is not really for me but I can't say
it's a failure it's just not it's not
what I want because like I said
Christmas specials they're not really um
they're just not really my jam broadly
speaking but this one's pretty good at
the end of the day so what are your
thoughts on it a Christmas Carol
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it if you
want to hand me an early Christmas
present there's the patreon link down
there that would be a massive help but
even failing that you could still like
subscribe share this video around that
helps me out as well there's other stuff
to check out down there besides I have
other channels including a secondary
channel for this called break room of
geeks which opened up fairly recently so
there's other links social media blah
blah blah
click on things buttons links they take
you places but you also don't have to
end of the day you're the council I'm
just running the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]